Netflix has a bad habit to kick and that
habit can be summed up in one word okay
after a recent report revealed that
depictions of smoking in its original
content have tripled in just the last
year the streamer has declared that they
will adopt a new much more restrictive
policy in regard to such depictions
going forward the move comes just days
after the release of the third season of
the hit series stranger things which
happens to feature a ton of
era-appropriate smoking yeah company
policy is a real drag the report was
released by truth initiative a nonprofit
organization that tracks the appearances
of tobacco products in major media it's
not the first time that the organization
had occasion to call out Netflix or even
stranger things for that matter a
similar report released in March 2018
took the streamer to task for featuring
182 smoking incidents across the 10
episodes which comprised the show's
first season with other original
offerings such as house of cards and
orange is the new black also coming
under fire the earlier report also
pointed out the troubling fact that
streaming services which aren't bound to
the same content standards that govern
traditional broadcast television are
extremely popular among young people
ages 15 to 24 an age group coveted as
potential customers by tobacco companies
the new analysts pointed out that the
trend of featuring characters who light
up on a regular basis hasn't just
continued it's exploded based on
estimated viewership of these programs
results suggest that approximately 28
million young people were exposed to
tobacco through television and streaming
programs in these most popular shows
alone that exposure is a significant
public health concern when the issue
first reared its head last year
Netflix issued what could be described
as a non-response while streaming
entertainment is more popular than ever
we're glad that smoking is not we're
interested to find out more about this
study this new missive however appears
to have gotten the streaming giant's
attention as viewers were watching
stranger things police chief Jim hopper
puffing away throughout the latest batch
of episodes Netflix was putting together
a detailed statement which it released
to Entertainment Weekly it read in part
Netflix strongly supports artistic
expression we also recognize that smoke
cooking is harmful and when portrayed
positively on screen can adversely
influence young people going forward all
new projects that we commissioned with
ratings of TV 14 or below for series or
PG 13 or below for films will be smoking
an e-cigarette free except for reasons
of historical or factual accuracy for
new projects with higher ratings
there'll be no smoking or ecig arrests
unless it's essential to the creative
vision of the artist or because it's
character-defining
historically or culturally important the
statement also revealed that in addition
to making a concerted effort to cut down
on the buts there would be changes
forthcoming to its content warnings
starting later this year smoking
information will be included as part of
our ratings on the Netflix service so
our members can make informed choices
about what they watch after nearly two
decades of steadily falling numbers use
of tobacco products among teens has
recently spiked to be clear nobody is
pinning the spike on Netflix the reason
for the surge is the soaring popularity
of e-cigarettes such as the Joule which
have seen an explosion in use by teens
and young adults while the numbers for
combustible cigarettes have remained
about the same it's worth noting that
the decades-long drop in the number of
teen smokers came during a time when
references to tobacco products were
being carefully stripped away from
broadcast television so it's certainly
possible that the more smoking friendly
streaming services which now filled more
original series than broadcast networks
for the first time ever could contribute
in some small way at least to plateauing
or even a reversal of the trend stranger
things have happened
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]